we haven't seen much of prince harry and
meghan markle lately and that's prompted
a lot of speculation
but we may finally know why the royal
couple suffered a pregnancy heartbreak
earlier this summer that megan has never
talked about
until now
any woman when they're especially when
they're pregnant you're really
vulnerable losing a child means carrying
an
almost unbearable grief those are
megan's words as she writes about the
miscarriage that happened in july while
holding baby archie
quote i felt a sharp cramp i dropped to
the floor with him in my arms
something was not right i knew as i
clutched my firstborn child that i was
losing
my second in a just published new york
times op-ed the 39-year-old details how
harry helped her writing
i lay in a hospital bed holding my
husband's hand
i kissed his knuckles wet from both our
tears
i tried to imagine how we'd heal she
says she watched harry's heartbreak as
he quote
tried to hold the shattered pieces of
mine i can't imagine
the agony for any couple of losing a
child in this way the prince's uncle
earl spencer
offered condolences today on a british
morning show and it's so very very sad
all thoughts with them today et's
learned the duke and duchess knew at the
time the loss was something they wanted
to eventually share
and that harry did discuss the
miscarriage with his family
compassion means seeing the pain and
suffering of others
and knowing that it's our duty to try to
help relieve it
that's megan speaking out in july around
the time of her and harry's loss
looking back at the sussex summer there
was one sign
another baby was on the way july 10
megan in a flowy linen dress was seen
leaving a doctor's appointment with
harry in beverly hills
they didn't emerge back in public until
august working through the pain to help
others
just weeks after the miscarriage the
couple handed out supplies to needy
children
and families in l.a i think we all know
how good it feels just to be around
positivity and
optimism that's what you're doing and we
need more of that they also spoke with
young leaders and megan took part in a
virtual summit
tackling women's issues i thought how
can i best support
this initiative and this incredible
media platform
in today's op-ed megan encourages
everyone to heal from a tough
2020 by committing to asking others
are you okay thank you for asking
because not many people have asked if
i'm okay
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes
we just send our love to megan harry
archie and their entire family